Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 296, recht wahrscheinlich das letzte im Jahr 2024.
Wo wir uns wie immer mit einem Thema beschäftigen, das wir uns mal so ein bisschen
näher angucken wollen, um dann darüber nachzudenken, das hat auf jeden Fall
was mit dem Digitalen zu tun, gefällt uns das so, wie das gerade ist oder müssen
wir Dinge anders machen?
Das führt relativ häufig dazu, dass irgendwie Dünge angezündet werden wollen,
manchmal wird die Welt auch ein kleines bisschen besser. Mal sehen, wo es heute hingeht.
Heute geht es nämlich um Digitalzwang oder Digital- und App-Zwang.
Oder um es anders zu sagen, um die Bereiche unseres Lebens, die digitalisiert
sind und manchmal nur noch digitalisiert möglich sind.
Und die Frage, ist denn das so eine gute Idee und welche Ansprüche muss man haben, wenn das so ist?
Das ist so die ganz kurze Zusammenfassung, die euch in der nächsten reichlichen Stunde erwartet.
Und das mache ich natürlich nicht alleine. Ich bin nur hier,
um das Geländer zu sein und die Dinge im Zaum zu halten.
Bei mir ist auch Konstanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Tag. Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin mir mittlerweile unsicher, was ich dir vorstellen soll.
Die Autorin von Netzpolitik.org, eine der SprecherInnen vom Chaos Computer Club,
die Podcast-Host von Dicke Bretter, die andere Hälfte des Chaos Radios.
Wem möchtest du heute sein? Expertin für Digitalzwang?
Eigentlich möchte ich heute, vielleicht bin ich heute mal Digitalisierungsopfer
und beschreibe lieber mal meine wünschenswerte Welt der Digitalisierung, die ich gerne hätte.
Ich bin natürlich irgendwie alles. Okay, herzlich willkommen,
Konstanze Kurz, Digitalisierungsopfer.
So, dann haben wir noch dabei Jana Mattert vom Deutschen Blinden- und Sehbehindertenverband.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ja, hallo.
Und dort mit dem Schwerpunkt digitale Barrierefreiheit.
Und da stelle ich gleich mal eine Frage mit der Bitte um kurze Antwort,
weil ich noch einen Gast vorstellen muss dann.
Barrierefreiheit und Zwang, hat das was miteinander zu tun?
Also, die Frage kann ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt gar nicht einordnen.
Barrierefreiheit und Zwang hatten ja erstmal nichts zu tun, weil Barrierefreiheit
ist ja eigentlich etwas total Positives und das, was wir uns als Ziel gesetzt
haben, die Gesellschaft in eine Richtung zu treiben,
wo Barrierefreiheit Standard ist, um sicherzustellen, dass Menschen mit Behinderung
vollumfänglich teilhaben können.
Und insofern würde ich erstmal sagen, weil Zwang so negativ behaftet ist, nein.
Barrierefreiheit und Zwang finde ich eine Kombination, die mir zumindest in
meinem Berufsleben noch nicht untergekommen ist.
Ich dachte jetzt eher so in die Richtung sozusagen, also wenn wir von etwas
reden, wo das Digitale zwangsweise den Menschen übergeholfen wird,
dann soll es barrierefrei sein und keine zusätzliche Barriere einführen.
Hätte ich so in die Richtung, hätte ich vielleicht gedacht.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir im weiteren Verlauf des Gesprächs vielleicht noch
dazu. Okay, eine zu schwierige Frage für eine einfache Antwort,
das klären wir also gleich noch, aber nicht bevor wir Jürgen Behring kennengelernt
haben. Der ist bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
Wer die nicht kennt, das ist, wie soll man sagen, eine Nichtregierungsorganisation
zur strategischen Prozessführung. Ist das richtig so?
Genau, das ist es. Also wir führen Verfahren und probieren Grundsatzurteile zu erwirken.
Und du leitest dort das Center for User Rights. Also das heißt,
du hast einen digitalen Schwerpunkt.
Genau, also beim Center konkret befassen wir uns sehr viel mit Plattformen,
Big Tech und wie wir dort die Rechte von NutzerInnen stärken können.
Ich habe aber auch schon mit vielen anderen Themen bei der GFF zu tun gehabt,
aber alle so im digitalen Bereich.
Es gibt ja so Schnittmengen zwischen GFF und der, sage ich jetzt mal,
Hacker, Nerd, Chaos, Bubble.
Ich glaube, man vergisst das vielleicht sogar dann aus dieser Perspektive,
dass die GFF generell strategische Prozessführung macht und nicht nur Digital-Krams.
So, und wir wollen heute über Digital- und App-Zwang, was das ist,
ich sage jetzt einfach nur Digital-Zwang reden.
Und als erstes müssen wir natürlich klären, was ist das, was verbirgt sich dahinter für ein Konzept?
Du hast dich ja als Opfer vorgestellt hier. Was ist Digitalzwang für dich?
Naja, die Idee zu der Sendung kam uns deswegen, weil der Begriff einfach in
diesem Jahr, also 2024, falls ihr die Sendung irgendwann hört,
weiß ich nicht, 2030, sehr viel häufiger gefallen ist.
Und weil mir persönlich in sehr vielen Veranstaltungen begegnet ist,
dass Leute ganz viel Diskussionsbedarf haben dazu und alle sehr viele konkrete
Beispiele nennen können.
Und die prominenteste werden wir bestimmt gleich besprechen,
nämlich natürlich die Deutsche Bahn und ihre App.
Und das war ja auch in diesem Jahr die Debatte darüber. Und ich glaube,
so ist der Begriff eigentlich aufgekommen und er beschreibt einen gewissen Unwillen.
Dass man in bestimmte Digitalisierungsprojekte hineingedrängt wird,
die einem vielleicht in der Form oder so nicht gefallen.
Insbesondere, dass man bestimmte App installieren muss, dass man bestimmte Dienstleistungen
nur noch angeboten bekommt in digitaler Form und dass es an Ausweichmöglichkeiten im Analogen fehlt.
Kann man jetzt, glaube ich, noch weiterziehen? Ich bin vor allem ein bisschen,
enttäuscht, weil du hattest dir vorgestellt, als jemand, der sozusagen auch
gerade digitalzwangs geworden ist und erzählt jetzt von einem theoretischen
Problem, das auf Konferenzen an dich herangetragen wurde.
Ich bin natürlich auch ein Bahnopfer, also wie die meisten Menschen,
viele Millionen sind betroffen bei der Deutschen Bahn, aber mir geht es glaube
ich, also ich würde einfach nach ein paar Monaten Debatte auch mal gerne ein
bisschen in eine Richtung.
Besprechen, die sagt, was will man eigentlich idealtypisch gerne haben?
Genau, ich bitte dich nicht zu vergessen, dass wir für die HörerInnen des Chaos-Radio
nicht am Ende der Debatte nach ein paar Monaten einsteigen, sondern am Anfang anfangen.
Und eine Sache sozusagen, die man sagen kann, weil Konz das gerade schon erwähnt hat,
also ein Beispiel, an dem man gut A erklären kann, worum es geht und B,
wo man auch dann in Gratet lang wandern kann, den wir später vielleicht noch
aufmachen, ist die Bahncard.
Die Bahncard war bis jetzt eine kleine Plastikkarte, die man sich mitführen konnte.
Seit längerem gab es schon eine digitale Version, die in der Navigator-App der
Deutschen Bahn ein QR-Code, ein großer war.
Und das ist seit Mitte des Jahres, glaube ich, ich muss es jetzt ganz vorsichtig
formulieren, weil es gibt Feinheiten, die Plastikkarte wird abgeschafft und die Bahn sagt,
die Navigator-App ist jetzt eigentlich das Ding für die Bahncard.
Ob es noch Alternativen gibt, reden wir später noch drüber.
Das heißt, Digitalzwang ist für mich erstmal sozusagen weniger theoretisierend.
Es gibt einen Lebensbereich, da kann man was, was früher auch ohne Strom ging,
nur noch mit Strom machen. Muss.
Wenn es ein Bereich des öffentlichen Lebens ist, wie zum Beispiel Zug fahren
wollen, muss deswegen auch ein Zwang. Jürgen, was ist für dich Digitalzwang?
Ja, ich würde anknüpfen, was Konstanz schon gesagt hat. Also einfach,
dass wir gewisse Dienstleistungen nicht mehr wahrnehmen können,
ohne im Internet zu sein.
Also es kann erstmal sein über eine App, über aber auch einen Webbrowser oder ähnliches.
Aber ich habe eben keine Möglichkeit, das Ganze mehr einfach analog wahrzunehmen,
dadurch, dass ich zum Beispiel zu einem Schalter gehe oder ähnliches.
Und die Beispiele, die wir heute wahrscheinlich auch viel besprechen,
drehen sich ja dann wahrscheinlich spezifisch um Apps und das ist dann vielleicht
auch nochmal eine weitere Dimension.
Also nicht nur, dass ich nicht mehr das irgendwie analog machen kann,
sondern ich bin auch wirklich dann angewiesen auf eine ganz spezifische App.
Das ist also sozusagen nochmal ein krasserer Fall davon.
Also Digitalzwang, ganz schön Abstufung. Und Jana, was ist, was verstehst du,
Digitalzwang, wenn du das hörst, was ist für dich das Wort, wofür steht das?
Ähnlich so, wie das eben auch schon erläutert wurde, dass halt analoge Maßnahmen
zugunsten von digitalen Angeboten abgeschafft werden.
Und was ich vielleicht aus unserer Perspektive noch ergänzen würde,
ist, dass das nicht nur etwas zu tun hat oder dass das nicht nur Probleme bereitet,
weil Menschen unwillig sind.
Apps oder das Internet zu benutzen, sondern dass es hier bei diesem Thema halt
auch um Exklusion von bestimmten Gruppen geht,
die entweder aus Kostengründen oder weil sie es sich nicht leisten können,
keinen Zugang zu bestimmter Infrastruktur haben, also kein Smartphone haben,
mit dem sie dann diese digitalen Anwendungen vorhalten können Oder die aufgrund
von Kompetenzen nicht in der Lage sind,
komplexere Apps so zu benutzen, dass sie sich sicher fühlen.
Also das wäre unsere Perspektive darauf.
Also sozusagen gleich die Zielgruppe quasi definiert, beziehungsweise gesagt,
Digitalzwang ist, wenn Leute ausgeschlossen werden, die nicht digital sein können oder wollen.
Was mich sozusagen, das war jetzt fast schon die Antwort, ich will sie trotzdem
nochmal stellen auf meine nächste Frage, nämlich, wenn wir über Digitales versus
Analoges reden, und das ist natürlich sozusagen ein bisschen das Gegenüber, was sich hier aufmacht.
Gibt es ja die Menschen, die einfach digital sind und dann gibt es die, die es halt nicht sind.
Und es gibt es vielleicht auch in Abstufungen, aber es gibt ja auch wirkliche
Offliner, also sehr wenige Menschen mittlerweile, aber die wirklich gar nichts
mit dem Digitalen zu tun haben.
Dann gibt es das natürlich sozusagen in Maßen, also vielleicht Menschen,
die ein Computer haben oder die ein Gerät haben, das online ist,
aber kein Multifunktionscomputer oder kein Smartphone.
Kann mir einer von euch sagen, was dazu erzählen, wer sind denn eigentlich die
Leute, die nicht online sind, wenn man es mal so sagt? Ich würde mal vielleicht
sogar noch eine Dimension dazunehmen.
Also zunächst mal ist es nicht gleich verteilt in der Bevölkerung.
Das ist, glaube ich, hinlänglich bekannt. Das wird ja auch erhoben,
wie viele Leute wirklich Offliner sind und wie viele Smartphones haben.
Das sind ja statistisch mittlerweile mehr als Menschen, aber manche Leute haben ja mehrere.
Das ist natürlich auch irgendwie einkommensabhängig, keine Frage.
Und auch bildungsabhängig und altersabhängig.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt noch eine Dimension mehr als Offliner zu sein oder
im Prinzip alle digital zu machen.
Sondern es gibt natürlich auch die Menschen, die, wie würde man sagen,
sehr bewusst mit der Art der Dienstleistung umgehen und zum Beispiel ihren Betriebssystemen
und die sich bestimmten Gewohnheiten, die sich so etabliert haben,
zum Beispiel, dass man bestimmte Tech-Konzerne benutzt,
bestimmte Dienstleistungen Standard werden, die sich dem verweigern.
Also insbesondere die sich Google verweigern, damit fällt natürlich auch der
App Store weg oder die sich sozusagen bestimmten Datenschutzmissbräuchen ziemlich
kritisch gegenüberstellen.
Dieser Bereich der Gesellschaft ist auch noch da, den würde gerne noch dazunehmen,
weil man mit der Digitalisierung nämlich nicht nur den Zwang überhaupt Webseiten
oder eine App benutzen zu müssen verbinden muss, sondern auch noch eine bestimmte Art.
Und zumindest nach meiner Erfahrung verbinden viele mit Digitalzwang auch den
Zwang, App-Stores für die beiden großen Betriebssysteme auf Smartphones zumindest zu verwenden.
Und zumindest in der technischen Community stößt es auch oft auf Widerstand.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein Aspekt, den wir dazunehmen müssen. Okay.
Genau, und daran vielleicht anknüpfend, gibt es ja dann auch sogar noch manche
Apps, die auch sagen, man muss auch einen spezifischen Account haben,
also sich selbst vielleicht in der App einen Account anlegen,
aber dann vielleicht auch, man braucht dann auch noch einen Google-Account oder Apple-Account,
oder auch über Facebook-Account oder so und das hat ja auch alles seine Probleme, die das mit sich führt.
Also auch das ist was, was für viele Menschen dann dagegen spricht,
sich über so einen Account anlegen zu wollen.
Ich will mal kurz bei den Leuten bleiben sozusagen. Also das heißt,
es gibt, wenn man es ganz grob betrachtet, zwei Arten von Leuten,
die die nicht können und die die nicht wollen.
Also im Sinne von, ich hätte das Geld, um mir die Geräte zuzulegen.
Ich würde mich genug auskennen, um die Technik zu benutzen. Ich will aber nicht
aus Datenschutzgründen, weil ich mir keinen Akkord machen will und so weiter
und so fort. Oder vielleicht so nicht wollen oder nicht können.
Also ich denke, die Dimension ist bei denen, die nicht können,
auch immer, die es so nicht können, wie es angeboten wird.
Und das hat man bei denen, die nicht möchten, so wie bei denen, die nicht können.
Naja, also vielleicht, aber bei denen, die nicht können, gibt es ja welche,
die können absolut nicht.
Wenn ich nicht online bin, dann kann ich halt nichts Digitales benutzen.
Also da gibt es sozusagen wirklich einen also quasi einen Ausschluss,
der sich auch nicht aufheben lässt, egal wie gut man es macht.
Und dann gibt es halt die sozusagen, die es wegen der Art und Weise nicht benutzen.
Kann mir jemand von euch was über Bevölkerungsgruppen sagen?
Weil was ich mal beobachte ist, man sagt, ja, mit dem Nicht-Digitalen,
das sind halt die alten Leute.
Die sind da, denen ist das zu viel. Das gibt es natürlich alles und das ist
auch eine relevant große Gruppe, aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel über die spricht,
die nicht können, ist es ja wahrscheinlich auch eine anders alter Gruppe.
Hat jemand einen groben Überblick, wie man das sozusagen verorten kann?
Anhand der Warndebatte sind ja die Angaben vom Statistischen Bundesamt rumgereicht worden.
Da redet man etwa von 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung, die ganz überwiegend Senioren
sind, die gar nicht wirklich online sind, die einfach nicht teilhaben an diesem
digitalen Leben aber die Erhebung wäre sozusagen ja, die Welt der.
Der Adblocker und Google Verweigerer, die wird man sicherlich in statistischen
Zahlen sehr viel schwerer.
Warte mal, aber das klingt jetzt sozusagen, als ob es sozusagen so ein binäres
Ding gibt, es gibt die alten Menschen, die nicht können und es gibt die jüngeren
Menschen, die nicht wollen gibt es nicht aber auch ich sag jetzt mal,
nicht alte Menschen die nicht können,
Also zum Beispiel, weil sie es sich nicht leisten können oder so?
Ja, in der Bahn-Debatte war auch tatsächlich, da haben sich die Sozialverbände
auch zu Wort gemeldet und natürlich betont, dass ein Smartphone auch ein sehr teures Gerät ist.
Da hat natürlich die Deutsche Bahn auch relativ offensiv gegen gehalten und
dann gesagt, naja, man muss ja nicht ein neues Gerät haben, man kann ja auch
ein altes haben. 100 Euro sind ja nicht viel Geld.
Genau. Klassischer Satz von jemandem, für den 100 Euro nicht viel Geld sind.
Also es gibt ganz sicherlich auch eine Einkommensdiskriminierung,
denn es geht ja auch oftmals darum, dass man als Grundlage ein sehr neues Betriebssystem haben muss.
Ältere Geräte sind teilweise schwer zu updaten, also es gibt schon gewisse technische
Gründe, die bei älteren Geräten dazu führen, dass man nicht alle von diesen
Digitalisierungsangeboten auch annehmen kann.
Jana, hast du sozusagen aus deiner Perspektive noch, was sozusagen,
wer wird, wenn es um Digitalzwang geht, außen vor gelassen? Kannst du das noch
ein bisschen eingrenzen?
Eingrenzen vielleicht nicht, aber ich würde nochmal auf den Punkt von Konstanze
zurückkommen, dass können, also nicht können, dass es nicht nur auf Offline,
Online reduziert werden sollte,
sondern tatsächlich auch darauf, wie sicher fühle ich mich im Umgang mit digitalen Angeboten.
Und dann guckt man halt nicht nur aus der Perspektive,
welche Kompetenz Bildung bringen Nutzerinnen und Nutzer mit,
sondern auch aus der Perspektive, wie sind digitale Angebote eigentlich gestaltet,
wie intuitiv, wie nutzerfreundlich sind sie.
Genau. Vielleicht vielleicht nochmal einen Aspekt. Kann man das ein bisschen genauer sagen?
Jetzt also statistisch? Ja, nee, also wie gut.
Also ich frage mich sozusagen, gibt es da eine Grenze, wo man sagen kann,
okay, ab hier ist es Zwang und ab hier ist es sozusagen, hier muss der Einzelne
einfach genug Aufwand betreiben und dann ist es schon okay.
Jana?
Also ich würde ja so definieren
wie wir das am anfang auch gesagt haben nämlich dass ich keine möglichkeit habe
auf analoge maßnahmen umzusteigen und ich finde die relevanz hängt stärker davon ab,
wie stark das die Teilhabe von Menschen beeinflusst.
Und gerade bei der Abschaffung der Bahncard sprechen wir von Mobilität und dass
Menschen von Mobilität ausgegrenzt werden.
Und gerade bei der Abschaffung der Bahncard haben wir halt auch gesehen, oder was dieses,
Armutsargument auch noch mal stärkt ist, dass auf der einen Seite,
wie wir ja schon gesagt haben,
dass Leute, die vielleicht nicht den großen Geldbeutel haben.
Auch davon betroffen sein können oder zu der Gruppe gehören,
die halt weniger digital unterwegs sind.
Und da kam halt obendrauf, dass die Bahn nun ausgerechnet die Angebote digitalisiert
oder digital only anbietet,
die so günstiges Bahnfahren betreffen.
Also die Bahncard und zwar nur die 25er und 50er, die 100er Bahncard bekommt
man immer noch als Plastikkarte und es betraf,
also vor der Abschaffung der Bahncard betraf es halt auch schon die Sprachpreistickets.
Also hier wurde insbesondere das günstige Bahnfahren auf Digital-Only umgestellt
und das hat natürlich in zweifacher Weise dann diejenigen betroffen,
die darauf angewiesen sind. Das ist immer ein spannender Punkt.
Jetzt würde ich euch nämlich mal fragen, ob ihr wirklich die Bahncard unter
Digitalzwang einsortieren wollt, weil man kann sie sich ausdrucken.
Man kann sich die Bahncard auf Papier ausdrucken.
Dann kann man natürlich sagen, ja, aber dazu brauche ich ja einen Computer und
einen Drucker und alles. Nee, man kann auch zur Bahncard, man kann sozusagen
zu einem Bahnschalter gehen und sagen, hier lieber Bahnschalter,
könnt ihr mir die Bahncard ausrufen? Die sind angehalten, das zu machen.
Und dann könnte man immer noch sagen, man braucht aber für diesen Prozess eine E-Mail-Adresse.
Also den Prozess, eine Bahncard zu erhalten, setzt eine E-Mail-Adresse zwingend
voraus. Und da ist auch der Punkt, da macht die Bahn keine Abstriche.
Ich habe gehört, man kann da auch irgendwas eingeben, also sagen,
es muss keine funktionierende E-Mail-Adresse sein.
Wenn du an den Schalter gehst und sagst, bitte druck mal das aus,
kannst du halt irgendwas, was von den Textzeichen her in der Mail-Adresse,
aber es muss nichts mit dir zu tun haben. Das heißt.
Jürgen, vielleicht könntest du als erster gleich antworten. Juristisch gesehen
ist es kein Digitalzwang, weil ich habe ja die Möglichkeit, völlig analog eine Bahncard zu halten.
Praktisch gesehen muss ich mich zur Bahn bewegen und dort Aufwand betreiben
und habe auch ein Problem, wenn das irgendwie nicht geht.
Ist die Frage, ist es jetzt Digitalzwang oder nicht?
Ich würde es schon als Digitalswang einordnen und zwar aus zwei Gründen.
Das eine ist das Formale, was du gesagt hast, ich brauche ja eigentlich eine
E-Mail-Adresse und ja, jetzt kann ich da vielleicht was anderes eingeben,
aber was ist denn, wenn mir die Bahncard verloren geht oder ähnliches und dann
muss ich natürlich irgendwie auch nachweisen, dass ich die gleiche Person war
und plötzlich stimmt die E-Mail-Adresse nicht.
Aber das ist jetzt so ein recht formales Argument. Das, glaube ich,
wichtigere, praktischere ist ja das, nochmal anknüpfend an den Begriff Digitalswang.
Ich glaube, es reicht nicht aus, wenn wir sagen, es gibt irgendeine Möglichkeit,
ganz egal mit wie vielen Widerständen das zu tun hat, dass ich das doch irgendwie die Leistung bekomme.
Sondern eigentlich muss es auch eine Möglichkeit geben, dass es schon auch realistisch,
also natürlich auch mit irgendwie Aufwand, aber eben nicht mit so viel Aufwand,
dass quasi doch alle Menschen praktisch davon abgeschreckt oder eben doch faktisch
ausgeschlossen werden.
Und das sehe ich hier eigentlich schon in dem Fall. Jana?
Ich würde da nochmal auf das Thema E-Mail-Adresse und kann ich da irgendwas
angeben, eingehen, weil ich finde das gar nicht so formal.
Weil die Bahn sagt, dass sie schnell und unkompliziert mit ihren Kundinnen und
Kunden kommunizieren möchte.
Und da ist ja schon die Frage, welche Mails gelangen dann an diese Mailadresse?
Kommen dann auch quasi Geschäftsbedingungen oder irgendwas an diese Adresse,
wo es eigentlich notwendig wäre, dass ich davon mitbekomme.
Und wie verantwortlich bin ich eigentlich dafür, diese Mails halt tatsächlich auch zu checken.
Das finde ich zumindest bislang ziemlich unklar. Ja, deshalb bin ich mir auch
unsicher, inwieweit man Leuten empfehlen sollte, hier irgendwas anzugeben.
Und dann geht es halt schon in Richtung, wenn ich dafür verantwortlich bin,
diesen Schriftverkehr mit der Bahn dann auch zu verfolgen, dann muss ich halt
auch online sein und dann muss ich meine Mails auch checken.
Aber das wäre vielleicht auch eine Frage an den Juristen, wie das dann aussieht.
Also ich würde gerne, wenn man ganz kurz von dem Beispiel. Ich würde gerne Jürgen antworten lassen.
Achso, zu dem konkreten. Genau, bin ich sozusagen, bin ich als Kunde verpflichtet,
die Mails zu empfangen oder kann man daraus dann einen Strick drehen?
Theoretisch kann einem schon auch ein Strick draus gedreht werden.
Also ich kenne jetzt das genaue Formular oder ähnliches nicht,
aber grundsätzlich, wenn ich irgendwie sage, hey, das ist jetzt auch für mich
persönlich wichtig, dass du da deine richtige E-Mail-Adresse angibst,
und da einfach sozusagen falsche Angaben gemacht werden, kann das im Zweifelsfall
auch dazu führen, dass zum Beispiel irgendwie ein Vertragsverhältnis beendet
werden könnte oder ähnliches.
Das sozusagen auf der sehr, sehr juristischen Ebene. Ansonsten ist,
ich glaube, der wichtigere Punkt ist eben wirklich der Medianer.
Also was ist denn, wenn da tatsächlich irgendwie kommt, Die AGBs werden aktualisiert,
ich muss jetzt widersprechen.
Andere Informationen kommen, beispielsweise auch irgendwie einfach die Frage,
es gab Missbrauch mit meiner Karte.
Es kann ja wirklich sehr, sehr viel relevante Informationen kommen,
bei der die Bahn ist dann automatisch, weil sie wird jetzt nicht checken,
ist das überhaupt eine E-Mail-Adresse, sondern es wird einfach irgendwie rausgeschickt.
Und das kann ich dann alles nicht wahrnehmen. Also ich gebe mich da schon ein
großes Risiko und ich würde auch juristisch niemandem empfehlen zu sagen,
gib da einfach mal irgendwas ein.
So, Konz, du versuchst die ganze Zeit vor der Antwort zu drücken,
aber auch du sagst, ist die Bahncard in der Zeit in Form Digitalzwang, ja oder nein?
Ich würde sie auf jeden Fall als Digitalzwang klassifizieren,
weil ich gerne die Definition ein ganz bisschen verändern möchte.
Das liegt daran, dass das Bahnbeispiel für mich relativ krass ist.
Da kannst du jetzt natürlich über die ein paar Graubereiche reden.
Ich habe verschiedene E-Mail-Adressen, die ich bei der Deutschen Bahn verwende.
Ich weiß genau, was die für E-Mails rausschicken und so.
Aber mir geht es nicht um diese, da ist eine feste Grenze, wo die etwas überschritten
haben. Sondern für mich beginnt der Digitalzwang viel früher.
Und die Veranstaltungen, die ich ganz am Anfang mal ansprach.
Die haben mir unglaublich viele Beispiele geliefert, Wo normale Menschen mir
von viel kleineren Dienstleistern erzählen oder aber auch noch viel schlimmer
von staatlichen Leistungen,
die nur noch digitalisiert angeboten werden,
wo diese Definition gar nicht stimmen würde, weil wenn man wirklich sucht,
findet man noch die analoge Möglichkeit,
aber sie wird so gut versteckt, sowohl von den Dienstleistern als auch von staatlichen
Stellen, dass man sie faktisch nicht mehr findet oder dass einem Steine in den
Weg gelegt werden oder auch Geld belegt.
Ja, sozusagen, dass man mehr bezahlen muss, wenn man die analoge Variante benutzt.
Und davon sind mir so viele Beispiele erzählt worden.
Da möchte ich mal hängenbleiben, weil nämlich für die armen Leute,
die diese Diskussion dieses Jahr erfolgt haben, dann hängt das Bahnbeispiel
wahrscheinlich schon zum Hals raus.
Deswegen, liebe Gästinnen, könnt ihr jeder vielleicht noch ein anderes Beispiel
für Digitalzwang nennen, was sozusagen kurz beschreibt, worüber wir reden.
Konz, weil du gerade so schön vorgelegt hast. Also ich kann einen kurz erzählen
auf dem staatlichen Bereich, betrifft ja nicht nur Berlin.
In Berlin kann man faktisch keine Bürgeramtstermine machen, schon länger nicht
mehr, das ist ein großes Problem.
Aber einige der Dienstleistungnehmer ganz einfache, wenn man zum Beispiel eine
Auskunft von einem Amt braucht, zum Beispiel eine Meldebescheinigung,
die kann man theoretisch auch analog machen.
Aber das ist wirklich ein riesen Problem auf den Berliner Webseiten,
die dafür extra angelegt sind, die analoge Variante herauszufinden.
Die verweigern auch die Angabe der Adressen, die muss man sich dann woanders
suchen, also der Postadressen.
Das ist wirklich ein Problem, dass die eben auch diese Nudging,
das sogenannte Hinschieben der Bürger auf die digitale Variante ganz stark,
also wirklich auch so mit der Gestaltung der Webseiten,
mit der konkreten Benennung der Alternativen und auch was die kosten.
Ja, das wird stark unterdrücken.
Die anderen Beispiele, die ich aus dem privatwirtschaftlichen Bereich nennen
würde, sind alles so ganz typische Sachen.
Ja, da kann eine Oma ihr Enkelkind nicht mehr beim Sport anmelden,
weil das alles nur noch digital gibt, aber sie hat eben kein Smartphone.
Also diese Beispiele sind natürlich der Klassiker.
Da könnte man bestimmt jetzt noch irgendwo hingehen zu dem Verein und sagen,
oh bitte kann ich trotzdem meinen Enkelsohn anmelden.
Aber das ist ein faktischer Zwang für die Menschen und das hinterlässt sie bedrückt
und manchmal auch ärgerlich.
Also von diesen kleinen Beispielen könnte man sehr, sehr viele nennen.
Vereinswesen und so weiter.
Bei staatlichen würde man sicherlich auch außerhalb von Berlin sehr viele Beispiele finden.
Jana, hast du auch noch ein Beispiel? Also für den DBSV muss man ja sagen,
dass wir mit der Abschaffung der Bahncard erstmalig uns zum Thema Digitalzwang quasi geäußert haben.
Wir haben ja zusammen mit Sozialverbänden so einen offenen Brief an die Bahn
damals gemacht und da erstmalig das Wort Digitalzwang dafür auch verwendet.
Was ich vielleicht sagen kann, bei uns im Verband ist auch schon länger,
gibt es da eine Diskussion über das Verhältnis von analog und digital.
Das macht sich so an unterschiedlichen Bereichen fest.
Also zum Beispiel hatten wir oder hatten und haben wir eine Diskussion darüber, wie man mit...
Mit Haushaltsgeräten umgehen soll, die zunehmend über Touchscreen bedienbar
sind und damit rein visuell und nicht mehr barrierefrei für Menschen mit einer Sehbeeinträchtigung.
Und dann gibt es häufig den Hinweis, dass diese Haushaltsgeräte,
dass die ja über App oder Smart Home Alexa auch bedienbar seien und dass darüber
die Bedienbarkeit einfach sichergestellt werden kann.
Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann halt durchaus auch diejenigen,
die sagen, es muss doch aber auch am Gerät bedienbar sein und es kann doch nicht sein,
dass ich auf eine App angewiesen bin, um meine Haushaltsgeräte zu bedienen.
Plus es gibt Haushaltsgeräte, wo man sich das schwer vorstellen kann,
zum Beispiel ein Herd mit vier Platten, den mit Alexa oder App zu bedienen, ist eher schwierig.
So eine andere Debatte, die wir sehr emotional auch geführt haben,
war eine Debatte um das Thema E-Roller.
Da beschäftigt uns sehr stark das Thema,
die Sicherheit von blinden und sehbehinderten Menschen durch die Abstellsituation,
die wir bei E-Rollern haben, gefährdet ist.
Also da gab es bereits schwere Unfälle von blinden und sehbehinderten Menschen,
die über diese E-Roller gestürzt sind und sich schwer verletzt haben.
Und auch da gab es Lösungsvorschläge, die dann gesagt haben, ja.
Mit einer App könnte man quasi Signaltöne von den E-Rollern auf dem Gehweg auslösen,
so dass Menschen mit Sehbeeinträchtigung dann entsprechend gewarnt werden und
um diese E-Roller herumlaufen können.
Und auch da gab es einfach eine Diskussion darüber,
ist das jetzt tatsächlich die Lösung, die wir wollen und weil es hier ja auch
einen ganz eklatanten Sicherheitsbereich und die Mobilität von Menschen mit
Sehbereinträchtigung betrifft.
Und da ist eigentlich, also jetzt speziell in diesem Fall auch bislang die Position des DBSV,
dass wir sagen, für E-Roller muss es Abstellflächen geben, um sicherzustellen,
dass hier keine Gefährdung von Menschen mit Sehbeeinträchtigung stattfindet.
Und so eine App kann ergänzend sein, aber wir brauchen da Abstellflächen,
auch weil, wenn man über barrierefreie Gehwege redet, dann auch Menschen im
Blick haben sollte, die...
Einen Rollstuhl benutzen oder einen Rollator und denen ist einfach überhaupt
nicht geholfen, wenn diese E-Roller ein Signalton abgeben.
Das ist für mich eine ganz neue Perspektive auf das Thema Digitalzwang,
also Digitalzwang nicht,
also zwei sogar, Digitalzwang ist nicht nur eine Dienstleistung,
die ich nur noch digital wahrnehmen kann, sondern es kann auch ein Gerät selbst
sein und sozusagen Digitalzwang in der sozusagen sehr,
also für mich verqueren Form im Sinne von, ein Problem gilt als gelöst,
wenn es eine digitale Lösung gibt.
Das ist natürlich totaler Quatsch, wenn ich das mal so deutlich sagen darf.
Aber Jürgen, an dich auch noch die Frage, hast du noch ein Beispiel für Digitalzwang?
Ja, mir fallen auch noch ein paar Sachen ein. Ich würde jetzt auch nicht alle ansprechen.
Ich probiere dich kurz zu fassen. Es gibt so ein paar Entwicklungen.
Also wir merken zum Beispiel, dass es einfach immer mehr ÄrztInnen gibt,
bei denen man Termine online bucht. und das ist halt, wenn irgendwie die einstige
Ärztin im Dorf ist, auch schwierig.
Paketdienste ist auch etwas, wo man halt häufig dann über Apps überhaupt noch
rausfinden kann, wo eigentlich das Paket gelandet ist.
Und zu guter Letzt haben wir auch viele im Bereich Studierenden gesehen.
Also dass zum Beispiel Studierendentickets auch dann häufig nur noch quasi per
App oder zumindest online verfügbar waren und auch schon Corona-Hilfen während, also Corona,
da war auch schon ein starker Drang dazu, digitalisiert unterwegs zu sein.
Es ist immer schön, wie es im Chaos gerade mal so noch eine Stufe fürchterlich
ist, als das, was man sich vorher so überlegt hat. Ich würde gerne noch eine
Dimension dazu bringen.
Mir ist so kürzlich bei einem Auslandsaufenthalt aufgefallen,
dass man natürlich, wenn man Tourist ist irgendwo oder eine Weile im Ausland
lebt, aber eben nicht zu den Inländern gehört, natürlich auch bei bestimmten
Digitalisierungszwängen besonders benachteiligt ist.
Bei den Studententickets wäre das auch so ein Beispiel. Also wenn ich als Austauschstudent
zum Beispiel komme, habe ich vielleicht nicht dieselben technischen Voraussetzungen.
Also es ist oft immer noch so, dass dann noch so eine Ebene dazukommt,
die sehr unangenehm ist.
Das betrifft zum Beispiel auch die ganzen Apps für die Verkehrsverbünde,
wo das oftmals sehr schwierig ist, wenn man nicht gerade Inländer ist und nicht weiß,
über welche Portale man da rankommt, weil es einfach keine kleinen Bütchen mehr
gibt, wo man sich ein Ticket kaufen kann in einer Großstadt und dann einen Tag rumfahren kann.
Ich würde, also das das Ding ist sozusagen, wenn man über Digitalsfall redet,
wie wir es jetzt auch hier gemacht haben, seit Anfang der Sendung,
ist ja zu sagen, das hat erstmal die Konnotation von was Schlechten.
Und das ist es auch. Aber es ist eben auch eine Begleiterscheinung von etwas,
was man, was eigentlich begrüßenswert ist, weil es sehr großes Potenzial hat,
nämlich die Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft.
Also, weil solange wir nicht vergessen, dass es das auch gibt,
ist Digitalisierung ja was Gutes.
Das heißt, man hat hier so einen, ich weiß nicht, ob Zielkonflikt das richtige
Wort ist, aber im Prinzip gibt es Lebensbereiche, wo man sich denkt,
wäre vielleicht ganz gut, wenn es digital auch ginge.
Und dann halt eben die nächste Frage, wenn wir vermeiden wollen,
dass wir ein Digitalzwangsproblem haben, wie stellen wir das an?
Und dann kann man die Frage wieder zweiteilen und nämlich, das eine ist sozusagen
das Offensichtliche, bei manchen Sachen muss es eine analoge Lösung geben oder
manche Sachen sind digital nicht zu klären.
Also E-Roller auf dem Gehsteig abstellen, also muss man sozusagen nicht über
eine digitale Lösung reden, weil da muss einfach der öffentliche Raum so gestaltet werden.
Und bei anderen Sachen ist es aber vielleicht diskutabel. Also bei sowas in
der Bahncard könnte man sich fragen, gibt es vielleicht eine Lösung,
die innerhalb der Digitalisierung funktioniert, die aber so funktioniert,
dass sie keinen Digitalzwang auslöst.
Ich stelle diese Frage beim Denken, ich weiß nicht, ob es da auch eine Antwort gibt. Ähm.
Und das führt uns dann zur Frage, wie unterscheiden wir diese beiden Probleme?
Also wie unterscheiden wir ein Digitalisierungsproblem, wo wir über die richtige
Digitalisierung reden müssen und wie erscheinen, wie stellen wir fest,
das ist ein Problem, da muss es eine analoge Variante geben.
Gibt es dazu Lösungsvorschläge, geneigtes Podium?
Ich mache gerne wieder irgendwie den Aufschlag und die anderen beiden können
dann total toll wieder spezifizieren oder verbessern.
Also für mich wäre wichtig, ist es eine Dienstleistung, die irgendwie zur kritischen
Infrastruktur und zum Alltag gehört und die einfach viele Millionen betrifft
oder ist es eher eine spezialisierte Dienstleistung. Da würde ich schon mal
qualitativ unterscheiden wollen.
Ich würde auch unterscheiden wollen, es wird eine staatliche Dienstleistung,
die Leute in Anspruch nehmen müssen, weil sie bestimmte Amtsgänge,
weil sie einen Ausweis brauchen oder einen Reisepass. Also da würde ich auch
nochmal klar unterscheiden.
Und ich würde eine ganz simple Anforderung stellen wollen, nämlich sind die
überhaupt gesetzmäßig? Wir haben ein paar Regeln.
Bei Barrierefreiheit sind die ja zum Beispiel auch gesetzlich geregelt.
Oder aber wir haben Datenschutzgesetze, sind die eigentlich eingehalten worden?
Und da werden sozusagen die ersten Stufen, die ich nehmen würde und dann kann
man das, finde ich, weiter spezifizieren.
Das ist auf eine Weise, das meine ich ganz am Anfang mit, ich will es vielleicht
nicht so, ich will die Digitalisierung, aber ich möchte sie auf eine andere Weise,
weil sie mich nicht zwingt, zu bestimmten großen US-amerikanischen Tech-Konzernen
zu gehen, sondern weil sie mir
eine Lösung angeboten wird, die frei ist im Sinne von frei von Tracking,
und auch frei mich auf bestimmte Plattformen zu zwingen und das wären so ein
bisschen meine Abstufungen, da fielen mir noch mehr ein, aber ich werde nicht
den ganzen Strauß aufmachen Warte mal, jetzt hast du wieder eine andere Frage
beantwortet als ich gestellt habe, weil was ich ja eigentlich wissen wollte
ist, wie unterscheiden wir Probleme.
Die eine analoge Lösung brauchen von denen die eine gute digitale Lösung brauchen,
Ich hoffte eigentlich, dass ich der Abstufung schon so mitgedacht habe.
Das heißt sozusagen Dinge, die sich, also dann muss ich das Verständnis frage,
sagst du, Digitalprobleme, die sich nicht deinen Anforderungen gemäß lösen lassen,
brauchen eine analoge Lösung? Ja, das würde ich schon so sagen.
Also das dauerhafte bestimmte Anteil der Bevölkerung irgendwie außen vor gelassen
würde mir bei dieser Art von Anwendung nicht okay finden.
Da können wir bestimmt auch nochmal in 20 Jahren anders debattieren,
wenn unsere digitale Welt anders aussieht. Aber so momentan unter den Bedingungen,
die auch viele als selbstverständlich annehmen, würde ich nicht so sehen wollen.
Und dann hattet ihr oft, um mal ehrlich zu sein, das ist ja noch ein Aspekt,
den wir vielleicht irgendwo noch mit reinstrecken müssen in die Gemengenlage.
Im Prinzip wollen sie doch oft nur Geld sparen. Darum geht es doch sehr häufig.
Wenn Dienstleistungen im privatwirtschaftlichen Bereich sind,
aber auch teilweise im staatlichen Bereich, geht es echt oft um Kosten,
ja, Effizienzkostenoptimierung und zwar eben auf Kosten der Nutzer häufig.
Und da muss man von dem Unamount unterscheiden.
Wollen die eigentlich primär Personal abschaffen,
Dienstleistungspersonal, also zum Beispiel eben weniger Kundendienstzentren
anbieten müssen oder ist das eigentlich eine nette, wirklich durchdachte digitale Dienstleistung,
die die Kunden glücklicher macht und leider ist das häufig eher der erste als
der letztere Fall, das ist zumindest meine Erfahrung bei Digitalisierung.
Ich bin jetzt gespannt, was die anderen sagen.
Also einerseits zu dem Ding sozusagen, nee, wenn es digital gut ist, ist es schon okay.
Und andererseits zu dem, du hast doch so einen qualitativen Unterschied gemacht,
wenn es sozusagen ein Nischending ist, dann ist es nicht so wichtig.
Für mich ist ja Inklusion immer auch, dass alle an allem teilhaben können.
Von daher bin ich jetzt gespannt, was Jana und Jürgen dazu sagen.
Ja, bin ich auch gespannt.
Soll ich? Ich kann, ja, bitte.
Also zu der Frage, in welchen Bereichen brauchen wir das eigentlich?
Ich glaube auch, dass man da ein bisschen differenziert. Also niemand würde
jetzt sagen, Tinder muss es auch offline geben oder so.
Gutes Beispiel.
Gleichzeitig, ich glaube... Entschuldigung, da musst du mal die Prinzipienfragen stellen. Weil...
Ist es fair, wenn Dating nur noch digital stattfindet? Ja, bei Tinder ist nicht die einzige Plattform.
Genau, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Punkt an der Sache.
Also ich glaube, die Frage, die wir uns zuerst stellen ist, ist es überhaupt
eine Dienstleistung, die auch analog angeboten werden kann?
Und da, glaube ich, gibt es einfach schon welche, die es einfach gar nicht mehr gibt.
Und das ist ja häufig eher sozusagen, dass diese so Barn-Apps oder so,
die vermitteln uns ja einfach Dienste, die es aber auch im Analogen einfach gibt.
Und dann ist eine große Frage für mich auf der zweiten Ebene einfach,
ist es relevant fürs gesellschaftliche Leben?
Und ja, also es ist natürlich immer schwierig zu sagen, du hast dir jetzt irgendwie
was ausgesucht, das akzeptiere ich nicht als gesellschaftliches Leben,
dann hast du halt Pech gehabt.
Ich glaube, da muss man wirklich auch aufpassen, dass man da nicht wiederum
Leute auch ausschließt.
Aber ich glaube, es ist schon auch eine wichtige Dimension, damit man auch das
anknüpft, was Konstanz auch staatlich gesagt hat.
Also ja, staatlich stimme ich vollkommen zu, aber es gibt einfach mittlerweile
mehr und mehr Dinge, wo man eigentlich sagt, irgendwie ist das schon fast wie
eine staatliche Aufgabe, die aber auf Private ausgelagert wird.
Und da müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir die nicht aus dem Auge verlieren.
Und zur Frage mit dem Geld wollte ich auch noch ganz kurz was sagen.
Und zwar genauso sehe ich das eben auch, dass es hauptsächlich häufiger nicht
darum geht, Digitalisierung voranzubringen, sondern Geld einzusparen.
Und das sehen wir vor allem daran, sozusagen gibt es wirklich Bereiche,
wo man sagt, okay, da macht Digitalisierung erst Sinn, wenn wir eine gewisse
Masse an Menschen erreicht haben, die es nutzen.
Und da gibt es einen Sicherheitbereich, aber häufig ist es ja so,
dass man hat auch noch hin den Faktor, der zur Digitalisierung treibt,
wenn eine gute App vorhanden ist. Dann werden die Leute, die eine App nutzen
können, die auch nutzen.
Aber dazu muss man ja auch nicht sagen, andere Leute dürfen das gar nicht mehr machen.
Und ich glaube, da haben wir häufig einfach die Einschränkungen.
Und wie gesagt, ich stimme schon zu, es geht häufiger eher ums Geld,
als zu sagen, ohne Digital zu fangen, ist Digitalisierung nicht möglich.
Jana? So, dann mache ich die letzte in der Runde.
In welchen Bereichen brauchen wir das? Also wir sind ja ein Verband,
der ganz stark Digitalisierung als Chancen sieht für Menschen mit Sehbeeinträchtigung.
Einfach, weil mit Digitalisierung ganz, ganz viele Möglichkeiten bestehen,
Dinge zugänglicher zu machen.
Ja, das kann man sich vorstellen bei zum Beispiel digitalen Dokumenten.
Die sind einfach vorlesbar, die kann ich mir über eine Breilzeile zugänglich machen.
Da kann ich die Schrift vergrößern, das ist einfach dort möglich. Oder das ganze Thema KI.
Da gibt es mittlerweile so viele Möglichkeiten und Vortritte,
was so Bilderkennung angeht.
Wo halt tatsächlich auch die Chancen bestehen, Teilhabe hier wirklich voranzubringen
durch Digitalisierung und Technik.
Deshalb stehen wir eigentlich Digitalisierung enorm positiv gegenüber.
Die Frage ist halt eher genau die, die hier auch gestellt wird.
Wie wird Digitalisierung gemacht?
Und da gibt es halt zum einen das Thema, das eben auch schon angeklungen ist,
dass Digitalisierung häufig als Effizienzgewinn durchgeführt wird.
Also dass gar nicht so sehr der Mehrwert für die Nutzenden im Vordergrund steht,
sondern dass Digitalisierung vorangetrieben wird, um Kosten einzusparen.
Und da würde ich vielleicht ergänzen wollen, auch zu Lasten von den Nutzenden,
weil wenn die Bahn künftig ihre Tickets nicht mehr analog verkauft und damit
entsprechende Infrastruktur wie Fahrscheinautomaten und so weiter und die Service Center abschafft,
Dann wälzt sie ja letztendlich ihren Kundinnen und Kunden über quasi diese technische Infrastruktur,
die sie da abbaut,
selber in irgendeiner Form zu kompensieren, indem sie halt voraussetzt,
dass alle halt ein Smartphone haben,
dass dieses Smartphone funktioniert und dass ich,
wenn die Zugbegleitung vor mir steht, halt auch in der Lage bin, dieses System.
Ticket, dieses digitale Ticket vorzuzeigen. Und ich kann ja nur sagen,
meine Erfahrung als Berufspendlerin ist, dass es nicht immer klappt.
Also ich habe jetzt mittlerweile so häufig in der Bahn die Diskussion und den
Ärger, dass irgendjemand sein digitales Ticket nicht vorzeigen kann.
Und das ist halt einfach abgewälzt.
Die Kosten, die die Bahn spart, die wälzt sie letztendlich ihren Kunden und Kunden über.
Das Zweite, von daher geht es, wenn wir über Digitalisierung sprechen,
aus unserer Sicht immer darum, auch Mehrwerte zu schaffen für die Menschen,
die digitale Angebote nutzen.
Und ein zweiter Punkt, der uns natürlich wahnsinnig umtreibt,
ist das Thema der Gestaltung und das Thema digitale Barrierefreiheit,
weil die Voraussetzung dafür,
dass Menschen mit Behinderung… Ich will kurz unterbrechen, weil ich habe ja gefragt nach,
wie unterscheiden wir Probleme zwischen digitalisierbar und analog und ihr fangt
alle an zu erzählen, dass es um gute Digitalisierung geht und ich möchte über
gute Digitalisierung auch gleich noch sprechen.
Dann haben wir alle deine Frage nicht richtig verstanden. Maybe.
Oder ihr seid heimliche Digitalisierungsfans und sagt, es ist schon alles okay,
man muss es nur richtig machen.
Ich habe noch ein Argument, wo ich auch eine Meinung zu wissen würde,
für warum es gut ist, immer auch eine analoge Variante zu haben.
Und das ist das, man hat die Wahl.
Also in dem Moment, wo eine Lösung nur noch digital vorliegt,
und es keine analoge Variante mehr dazu gibt, habe ich dann nicht mehr die Wahl.
Und das heißt sozusagen, es gibt keine Motivation, die digitale Lösung möglichst gut zu machen.
Ja, aber ich bin jetzt schon wieder frech und fang schon wieder an,
aber ich würde sogar noch zuspitzen. In Verzeihung, wenn Strom ausfällt,
kannst du nichts mehr bezahlen.
Also ich spitze mal das jetzt auf ein Payment zu.
Aber ist das nicht so ein Argument dafür, dass wir eigentlich für alle Lösungen
immer eine analoge Variante haben müssen?
Nicht nur wegen der Ausfallsicherheit, sondern auch damit überhaupt noch so
eine Art gesellschaftlicher Druck entstehen kann?
Ich finde es in manchen, also die Techniker nennen das oft Kritis,
also kritische Infrastruktursysteme.
Finde ich jetzt schon richtig. Also ich musste ein bisschen. Ich rede aber nicht,
es ist immer diese Einschränkung auf kritisch oder das müssen viele Leute,
ich meine das ganz generell,
ich meine das ganz generell, also keine Ahnung, Bezahlkarten,
es gibt für den öffentlichen Nahverkehr,
gibt das Konzept von Bezahlkarten, also sozusagen bargeldloses Bezahlen und
auch da kann man das argumentieren, wenn der Strom ausfallen würde,
dann könnte man den Bus nicht mehr bezahlen, ist vielleicht egal,
dann kann der Verkehrsbetrieb vielleicht sagen, gut, dann machen wir das heute halt ohne.
Aber wenn es halt gar keine nicht-digitalen Lösungen mehr gibt,
haben die Menschen nicht mehr die Wahl quasi mit den Füßen abzustimmen.
Das ist ein bisschen, was ihr vorhin gesagt habt. Eine gute digitale Lösung nehmen die Menschen an.
Aber wenn es gar keine Alternative gibt, dann gibt es halt sozusagen diese Wahl einfach nicht mehr.
Es ist deswegen sozusagen nicht vielleicht auch eine gute Idee,
darauf zu bestehen, dass es analoge Lösungen immer geben muss, damit man die Wahl hat.
Ja, sag du mal. Also ich würde ja sagen, in der Praxis zeigt sich das ja aber irgendwie gar nicht.
Also auch wenn man analoge Varianten hat, sind die digitalen Angebote ja zum
Teil nicht gut nutzbar, nicht barrierefrei.
Von daher weiß ich nicht, ob das, also ich verstehe das Argument,
aber ich finde es in der Praxis, ja zumindest aus der Perspektive Barrierefreiheit
und Nutzungsfreundlichkeit, Freundlichkeit,
stellt es sich für mich nicht so ganz dar. Jürgen, was hast du?
Grundrecht aufs Analoge.
Also dazu kann ich natürlich noch viel sagen, aber vielleicht zuerst mal zu
der konkreten Frage, wie übt das Ei überhaupt Druck aus oder nicht?
Ich würde sagen ganz, ganz wenig, weil ich glaube am Ende des Tages ist es so,
dass häufig auch einfach schlechte Apps genutzt werden und gerade zu diesem
sozusagen muss ich dann meine Apps besser machen, damit der analoge Service weniger genutzt wird.
Ich habe den Eindruck, häufig ist der Gedanke eher andersrum.
Ich mache einfach den analogen Service schlechter, damit dann der Digitale besser genutzt wird.
Also genau, ich glaube, es geht da eher in die andere Richtung.
Deswegen, ja, das kann man als Argument schon nehmen, aber ich würde halt nicht
sagen, dass es das Hauptargument ist, sondern das ist eher sozusagen Zugang
zu Dienst und damit auch teilweise eben auch Grundrechte.
Und um jetzt auf die grundrechtliche Frage nochmal zuzukommen.
Also es wird ja jetzt in diesem Jahr immer wieder gefordert,
auch nochmal aufzunehmen, direkt ins Grundgesetz.
Ein Grundrecht auf analoges Leben.
Und da ist so die Frage, brauchen wir das oder nicht?
Ich würde sagen, das ist einfach ein bisschen noch ungeklärt und das knüpft
jetzt dann auch wieder daran an, welche Dienste sind es.
Also ich glaube, so ein generelles Grundrecht auf analoges Leben haben wir nicht,
aber natürlich haben wir in einzelnen Bereichen natürlich schon auch Rechte,
dass ich eben den staatlichen Dienst in Anspruch nehmen kann und wenn ich den
nur noch digital in Anspruch nehmen kann, dann schließt das einfach Leute damit
aus und damit haben wir in vielen Bereichen schon auch einen gewissen Anspruch darauf.
Der sich auch durchsetzen lässt oder der moralisch besteht?
Nein, der wird sich auch durchsetzen lassen. Also da gibt es jetzt mittlerweile
die ersten Verfahren und Leute überlegen auch mehr und mehr,
wo könnte man was machen.
Also es ist ja einfach auch jetzt eine neue Entwicklung und man merkt dann immer
die Gerichtsentscheidungen.
Dazu kommen dann immer ein bisschen später.
Und wie das sich genau ausgestalten wird, das muss man noch sehen.
Aber ich gehe auch davon aus, dass auch gegen Deutsche Bahn geklagt wird.
Da gibt es auch schon viele Überlegungen. Es gibt auch schon erste,
kleinere Verfahren dazu und wir werden sehen, was dann dabei rauskommt.
Aber es wird wohl kaum das Ergebnis sein, dass der BGH sagt ja im Zweifelsfall,
dann nutzen halt manche Leute die Bahn nicht mehr oder eben einfach nur zu teureren Preisen.
Das kann ich mir wiederum kaum vorstellen.
Na gut, schauen wir mal. Ich finde, glaube ich.
So ein plattes Recht auf analog wird, glaube ich, einfach dieser ganzen ausdifferenzierten
digitalen Welt nicht mehr gerecht.
Ich glaube, die Unterscheidung, die wir heute schon gesehen haben und die ziemlich
unterschiedlichen Beispiele, auch gerade wenn man auch Janas Beispiel dazu nimmt,
die lassen sich schlecht, finde ich, mehr in diese Schablone drücken,
wir brauchen recht auf analog, weil so wird es nicht sein, sondern ich denke,
wir müssen klare Regeln setzen,
wie bei bestimmten wirklich wichtigen Dienstleistungen und Infrastrukturen eine
Digitalisierung gemacht werden muss.
Ja, ich denke, da...
Mir fallen auch ein paar Positivbeispiele ein, aber die überwiegende Zahl ist
halt nicht gerade super positiv und hat auch oft, finde ich,
gesetzliche Mängel im Sinne von der Umsetzung von rechtlichen Vorgaben,
dass einfach, ja, sich, ja.
Nennen das mal, ja, so Gegebenheiten als normal angenommen werden,
die wir vor zehn Jahren noch nicht akzeptiert hätten. Also da hat sich was eingeschlichen.
Und ich finde, das ist schon ein gewisses Zurückdrehen, was man damit fordern würde.
Aber ein Recht auf Analog wäre mir persönlich zu harsch. Also ich fasse die
Sendung bis jetzt mal zusammen. Ein Digitalzwang ist schon okay,
solange es richtig gemacht wird.
Du müsstest jetzt mal sagen, wie es richtig gemacht wird. Darf ich vielleicht
noch was zum Thema Recht auf Analoges sagen?
Also wir verfolgen die Debatte ja auch und aus unserer Perspektive wäre es zum
Beispiel auch ein Recht auf Digital durchaus auch wünschenswert,
weil natürlich auch wir mit dem Digitalen mehr Zugang erhalten.
Von daher finde ich eigentlich wesentlich besser geeignet in dieser Debatte
darüber zu diskutieren,
dass es halt mehrere Möglichkeiten des Zugangs geben sollte,
um halt Exklusionen zu vermeiden.
Und dafür gibt es ja durchaus auch Beispiele.
Also in der Landesverfassung Schleswig-Holstein
ist das zum Beispiel für Verwaltungsleistungen festgelegt,
dass sowohl persönlicher, schriftlicher und digitaler Zugang bestehen muss und
dass niemand aufgrund des Zugangs diskriminiert werden darf.
Und das finde ich eigentlich als Forderung viel angemessener als ein alleiniges
Recht auf analoges Leben.
Ja, das ist aber auch schon eine Abstufung, die eigentlich viel von dem,
was wir bisher so an Kritik angesprochen haben, schon drin hat.
Und da geht es ja doch wieder darum, wie wird sie gemacht.
Also da könnte ich mich auch weitgehend anschließen, glaube ich.
Okay, Jürgen wollte, glaube ich, gerade was? Genau. Noch zu deiner zugespitzten Zusammenfassung.
Digitalquellen ist okay, wenn auch gut gemacht wird. Natürlich nicht.
Also ich glaube, der Punkt ist, der Digitalisierung ist gut,
wenn sie gut gemacht wird.
Also wir können natürlich, man muss ja einfach sehen, vieles wird einfach auf
eine Art und Weise gemacht, dass wir jetzt Grundsätze, die wir ja sonst kennen,
Datenminimierung oder insgesamt einfach sozusagen Datenschutz einfach außen vor lassen.
Genau, so schöne juristische Worte einfach alles vorlassen.
Man kann das natürlich aber auch alles gut machen, aber selbst wenn man jetzt
die perfekte App hat, wo man sagt, ach, Datenschutz, super gut alles umgesetzt,
würde ich trotzdem nicht sagen, die Zahlzwang, ja, weil natürlich schließt es
auch dann noch Leute aus.
Also einfach Leute, die sich kein Smartphone leisten können.
Leute, die eben aus diversen Gründen einfach trotzdem nicht wirklich mit sowas umgehen können.
Sei es Alter, sei es einfach auch gewisse Vorbedingungen oder ähnliches.
Und das muss man immer noch mitbedenken. Das heißt, ja, Recht auf Digitalisierung
finde ich auch einen sehr, sehr guten Ansatz.
Aber das heißt ja nicht gleichzeitig Digitalzwang. Da bin ich nach wie vor kritisch.
Ich bin ja immer auf der Suche nach einfacher Antworten und was ich noch nicht
so ganz zu fassen kriege ist, dass ich.
Wenn ich sage, es muss eigentlich immer eine analoge Option geben,
dann höre ich, nee, muss es nicht,
Das wäre ja dann automatisch digital, sondern man sagt ja aber auch so,
nee, das ist aber auch nicht richtig.
Ich kriege tatsächlich noch nichts zu fassen sozusagen, weil jetzt nach dem,
was du jetzt in dieser Runde gesagt hast, würde ich mir denken so,
aha, es muss eben also doch eine Möglichkeit geben, das nicht digital zu nutzen,
also gerade mit dem, was Jürgen jetzt gesagt hat.
Aber vielleicht kommen wir am Ende nochmal hin und sagen, weil jetzt alle immer
sagen, also das Digitale muss aber auch gut sein. Was heißt denn das?
Was ist denn eine gute Digitalisierung? Damit fasst du doch eigentlich nur zusammen,
woran die Debatte auch im letzten Jahr so ein bisschen gekrankt hat.
Man nimmt sich immer irgendein Beispiel und spitzt sie zu.
Aber ich glaube, so sieht Digitalien nicht mehr aus und man muss unterscheiden,
wo man eine analoge Option braucht.
Ich sage literally meine erste Frage. Meine erste Frage ist,
könnt ihr unterscheiden, wo man die braucht und wo nicht? Ich habe keine klare
Antwort darauf bekommen.
Aber egal, wie sieht denn gut in der Digitalisierung aus?
Für mich sind natürlich die Aspekte wichtig, die teilweise schon angeklungen sind.
Und eine ist, sie darf sich nicht verbinden mit einem Zwang,
bestimmte große Tech-Konzerne zu benutzen. Das finde ich nicht richtig.
Gleich eine Folgefrage dazu. Gibt es dann für dich sozusagen akzeptable Anbieter?
Also nicht große Tech-Bieter, da gehe ich jetzt mal drauf aus.
Du meinst irgendwie Amazon, Google, Microsoft, Meta, Apple. So,
was heißt das sozusagen?
Es muss eine Wahl aus mehreren Anbietern geben? Muss es ein deutscher Anbieter
sein oder ein staatlicher? Man muss aus meiner Sicht vor allen Dingen erstmal eine Wahl geben.
Wo hole ich die App her, wenn es eine gibt? Kann ich auch gleichzeitig die Webseite
benutzen oder bin ich eben gezwungen, eine App runterzuladen?
Bin ich dafür zu bestimmten Betriebssystemen verpflichtet, wenn ja welche?
Kann ich mir vielleicht auch selber den Quellcode holen? Da gibt es ja verschiedene
Varianten und auch viele gute Beispiele.
Wir haben jetzt immer die schlimmen genannt. So, diese Richtung.
Prinzipiell würde ich mal sagen, bei der Barrierefreiheit und beim Datenschutz
würde mir zunächst mal genügen, wenn sie überhaupt die rechtlichen Verpflichtungen
einhalten. Das ist halt oft nicht der Fall.
Und dann, ja gut, wenn es tatsächlich so ist, dass es eine kritische Infrastruktur
ist, dann würde ich die Anforderungen höher setzen. Mhm.
Datensicherheit spielt keine Rolle. Naja, klar. Deswegen ja wenig Kritis. Also, ne.
Nee, ich meine generell, du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, sozusagen Anbieterauswahl, Barrierefreiheit,
Naja, die Tech-Konzerne spielen schon eine große Rolle. Also muss ich eine Accountpflicht haben?
Bin ich verpflichtet, das App zu haben oder kann ich es auch auf der Webseite benutzen?
Also wo hole ich die App her? Muss ich unbedingt über die App-Stores der beiden
großen Smartphone-Betriebssystem-Hersteller gehen oder kann ich es auch runterladen? Ist die Quell offen?
Natürlich, klar, typische Fragen, die sich aber bei fast allen Digitalisierungsprojekten
schon lange stellen. Deswegen kam ich darauf, weil ihr vorhin das Wort Zweckbindung
in den Raum geworfen habt.
Da geht es um die Art und Weise, wie die Daten verarbeitet sind.
Auch ein Kriterium. Naja, die Zweckbindung
ist eigentlich in der Datenschutzgesetzgebung festgeschrieben.
Du kannst die Zwecke, du wirst, wenn du personenbezogene Daten erhebst,
die immer an einen bestimmten Zweck binden müssen und kannst den Zweck näher einverändern.
Ich muss jetzt gerade wieder daran denken, dass Lauterbach diese Woche in den
Schlagzeilen war, dass er mit Google, Meta und noch irgendeiner Firma über die
Patientenakte geredet hat, was ich sehr fröhlich fand, aber es gab völlig andere
Themen. Entschuldigung, Jana.
Gute Digitalisierung. Wie sieht gute Digitalisierung aus?
Ja, darüber haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon die ganze Zeit gesprochen.
Also gute Digitalisierung, finde ich, darf A nicht dazu führen,
dass Gruppen von Menschen exkludiert werden.
Also sie muss Mehrwerte schaffen, aber sie muss natürlich auch so Qualitätskriterien
erfüllen und dazu gehört für mich die Einhaltung und Umsetzung der Standards
für digitale Barrierefreiheit dazu,
genauso wie Datenschutz oder IT-Sicherheit.
Kannst du, also wir haben schon einmal ein komplettes Chaosradio Nummer 275
warst du Barrierefreiheit gemacht, aber vielleicht kannst du,
ohne dass wir jetzt das Chaosradio sagen, könnte ich noch mal kurz sagen,
Anforderung an Barrierefreiheit, das ist ja sozusagen ein großes Ding,
was da drunter fällt?
Ja, also kurz sagen ist natürlich echt ein bisschen schwierig,
weil digitale Barrierefreiheit umfasst ganz viele Bereiche.
Also das umfasst ja nicht nur das Web, sondern da geht es auch um Hardware,
Software, Dokumente und so weiter. Und was für mich vielleicht wichtig wäre
zu sagen, ist, es gibt Standards, also man muss das Rad nicht neu erfinden.
Wir haben Standards, die beschreiben, wie man digitale Angebote barrierefrei
entwickelt und da geht es halt um die Einhaltung dieser Standards.
Mit den Standards ist allerdings auch so ein bisschen kompliziert,
weil wahrscheinlich hier in der Community sehr bekannt sind die sogenannten
Web Content Accessibility Guidelines, die WCAG,
ein internationaler Standard, der auch schon seit den 90er entwickelt wird.
Die, wie der Name schon sagt, für Web anwendbar sind.
Wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen, dass digitale Barrierefreiheit ja in bestimmten
Bereichen auch gesetzlich verankert ist.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel eine Verpflichtung von öffentlichen Stellen zur
digitalen Barrierefreiheit, ihre Webseiten und Apps auf der einen Seite.
Und wir haben das dritt ab Ende Juni nächsten Jahres in Kraft auch eine Verpflichtung
zu digitaler Barrierefreiheit für bestimmte Produkte und Dienstleistungen wie zum Beispiel Smart TVs,
Zahlungsterminals, Online-Shops und so weiter und so fort.
Die rechtliche Verankerung bezieht sich nicht auf die WCAG, sondern die bezieht
sich auf einen europäischen Standard, das ist die EN 301 549,
Barrierefreiheitsanforderungen für IKT-Produkte und Dienstleistungen.
Und das hat eine zunehmende, oder anders, wenn man in diese EN reinschaut,
dann findet man dort unterschiedliche Kapitel zu den Themen,
die ich eben auch, oder zu den Bereichen, die ich eben auch genannt habe,
Hardware, Software, Webdokumente.
Und wenn man in das Web-Kapitel reinschaut, dann wird man feststellen,
dass quasi da immer jeweils für ein Erfolgskriterium auf die WCAG verwiesen wird.
Also das ist mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1. Wir haben momentan, ist es so,
dass wir die WCAG in der Version 2.2 vorliegen haben.
In dem EN aktuell ist noch die 2.1 verlinkt, aber das ist auch so,
dass immer wenn die WCAG aktualisiert werden,
wird auch dieser Standard aktualisiert und da kommt auch eine Aktualisierung auf die WCAG 2.2.
Relevant wird das aber stärker, dass wir diesen EN-Standard haben,
wenn wir ab nächstem Jahr, wenn da nicht nur Web-Sachen drunter fallen,
sondern halt auch Hardware wie Bankautomaten, Zahlungsterminals und so weiter und so fort,
weil einfach die WCAG keine Hardware beschreiben.
Das findet man dann in diesem EN-Standard, der aktuell auch aktualisiert wird
daraufhin, dass die Anwendungsbereiche, die da ab nächstem Jahr verpflichtet sind,
dass die da auch in diesem EN-Standard abgedeckt sind.
Ich will sich gleich noch die Frage anschließen und sagen, es gibt ja anscheinend
genug Regeln, woran hapert es, dass die umgesetzt wird.
Aber vorher, Jürgen, noch mal gute Digitalisierung braucht was?
Eine grundrechtsfreundliche Digitalisierung, wobei das natürlich auch jetzt
einfach nur viel das, was schon gesagt wird, nochmal ausdrückt.
Also im Kern, es darf nicht zu einer Diskriminierung kommen,
wir müssen herüber unsere Daten bleiben und auch sonst sozusagen müssen wir
auf eine Art und Weise behandelt werden, dass unsere Grundrechte geschützt werden.
Aber natürlich sehe ich auf der anderen Seite auch die Punkte,
die schon angesprochen wurden, dass eine gute Digitalisierung nicht weiter dazu
beiträgt, zu der Monopolisierung, die wir schon im Tech-Markt sehen.
Und natürlich auch gleichzeitig auch eine gute Digitalisierung ist im Sinne
von, gute Produkte werden hergestellt, die funktionieren, mit denen man auch gerne arbeitet.
All das sind wahrscheinlich so die wichtigsten Aspekte.
Dann stelle ich jetzt die Frage, also im Prinzip von dem, was ihr sagt, ist ja auch alles da.
Es gibt die Richtlinien, es gibt die Gesetze, es gibt die Grundrechte.
Also wir haben die Frameworks, die man an so Sachen anlegen könnte, aber warum?
Naja, also das eine sieht man zum Beispiel an der aktuellen BVG App hier in
Berlin das ist die Verkehrsgesellschaft die hat halt irgendwie die Vorgaben
bei der Barrierefreiheit nicht hinbekommen bei ihrer App, ja dann macht sie halt bei der Version,
nächstes Jahr aber die, die schon hatten die alte Version, kriegen ein Update
durchgedrückt, die haben dann quasi eine nicht barrierefreie App Also es gab
eine barrierefreie Version und dann gab es ein Update Neue F.A. Ah, okay, verstehe.
Also es gibt so viel, das wird dann so als Nachlässigkeit dargestellt.
Aber der Punkt, den wir hier, oder alle Punkte, die jetzt genannt wurden,
sind, wie du schon sagst, in der Regel schon festgeschriebene Grenzen.
Ich würde mal wieder diese Grenzen auch anders setzen wollen.
Ich darf daran erinnern, dass die EU jetzt auch den Digital Fairness Act versucht,
in die Wege zu leiten. Ja, da geht es im Wesentlichen auch um Tracking und eine
Forderung von uns ist, ja, also jetzt vom TTC ist, dass.
Also personalisierte Profiling und Tracking sozusagen aus dem gesamten EU-Raum,
also quasi personalisierte Profiling und Werbung entfernt wird.
Aber für mich würde der Digital Fairness Act auch noch für den Bereich,
den wir heute besprochen haben, wichtig werden. Also zum Beispiel,
dass wird offengelegt werden muss, wenn ich eine digitale und analoge Variante habe.
Also wie mache ich es analog, wie mache ich es digital und wird dabei zum Beispiel
getrackt, werden dabei Daten an Dritte weitergegeben.
Also sozusagen die Transparenz, die nicht unbedingt eine gesetzliche Anforderung
ist, aber die einfach zu einer Fairness gegenüber dem digitalen Benutzer dazugehören würde.
Also so, man könnte halt auf EU-Ebene mehr durchsetzen, als heute schon in den Regeln steht.
Nämlich, dass diese, du hast das von denen dann mit den Füßen abstimmen.
Das ist überhaupt, also Jürgen hättet ja schon kritisiert und gesagt,
naja, das wird ja faktisch gar nicht gemacht.
Einfach weil es ja kein Nebeneinander der Angebote gibt, sondern das Nudging
hin zu dem Digitalen sehr stark ist.
Und das könnte man natürlich durch bessere Transparenz oder zum Beispiel durch
die Verpflichtung auf die analogen Wege auf hinzuweisen.
Oder auch auf etwa das Tracking bei digitalen Angeboten offen hinzuweisen.
Da könnte man ja vielleicht ein bisschen fairer gestalten.
Also da sind jetzt Regeln, die sind jenseits von dem, was wir genannt haben
und wären eher, naja, was eben unter diesem Fairness Act, den die EU da plant,
fallen würde, um verbraucherschutzfreundlicher zu machen.
Also es gibt sozusagen, es gibt schon viele Frameworks und es wird jetzt noch
ein neues geschaffen, es ist nur die Frage, wie wir es umsetzen.
Jana, woran scheitert deiner Meinung nach am häufigsten gute Digitalisierung?
Vielleicht kann ich so ein bisschen diese guten Frameworks nochmal infrage stellen,
weil was jetzt das Thema Barrierefreiheit angeht, haben wir auch wirklich noch
große Lücken in der rechtlichen Verankerung.
Und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel das Thema Barrierefreiheitsstärkungsgesetz nimmt,
was ich schon angesprochen habe, was dann ab 28.
Juni nächsten Jahres in Kraft tritt und wo bestimmte Produkte und Dienstleistungen
dann verpflichtend barrierefrei sein müssen, da ist es so, da gibt es einfach
eine Liste von Produkten.
Die in den Anwendungsbereich fallen. Und das hat dann so Kuriositäten zur Folge,
dass Online-Shops dann ab diesem Zeitpunkt barrierefrei sein müssen,
aber die Haushaltsgeräte, die ich da gegebenenfalls drin erwerbe, nicht.
Und wenn ich ein Paket an die DHL-Station gesendet bekomme, dann muss die auch
nicht barrierefrei sein.
Und das ist, ja, also Barrierefreiheit funktioniert halt nicht,
wenn nicht das durchdacht ist.
Also es gibt auch andere Beispiele, also wir haben da auch schon Nachfragen
bekommen, dass gesagt wird, okay.
Die Zahlung bei Automaten, die muss barrierefrei sein, aber wie sieht es denn
aus mit dem Scannen der Waren,
wo wir dann so sagen, na, aber wie soll denn ein Selbstbedienung,
also welchen Sinn macht es bei einem Selbstbedienungsterminal,
wenn ich barrierefrei zahlen kann, aber wenn ich den ansonsten nicht barrierefrei nutzen kann.
Und von daher haben wir auch, was die Frameworks oder was die gesetzlichen Verankerungen
angeht, haben wir noch enorme Lücken, die dringend geschlossen werden müssen,
weil unsere Erfahrung ist auch, dass ohne eine gesetzliche Verankerung geht
es in diesem Thema nicht voran.
Und selbst wenn man eine gesetzliche Verankerung hat, bei den öffentlichen Stellen
haben wir die und haben wir die auch schon seit längerem, scheitert es halt in der Umsetzung.
Weil die Prioritäten nicht entsprechend gesetzt werden und weil einfach die
Instrumente der Durchsetzung nicht gegeben sind. Das ist besser.
Bei den öffentlichen Stellen haben wir mittlerweile so einen Überwachungs- und
Durchsetzungsmechanismus,
wo es halt auf Bund- und Landesebene Überwachungsstellen gibt,
die stichprobenartig sich Webseiten und Apps öffentlicher Stellen anschauen.
Und da muss auch regelmäßig an die EU-Kommission darüber berichtet werden,
wie es denn damit aussieht.
Für den Überwachungszeitraum 2020-2021 wurde in diesem Bericht festgestellt,
dass nicht eine Webseite und nicht eine App, die da in dieser Stichprobe drin war.
Allen Anforderungen der Barrierefreiheit erfüllt hat.
Und demnächst kommt der nächste Bericht über den Überwachungszeitraum 2022 bis 2024.
Wir sind sehr gespannt, ob sich daran irgendwas geändert hat.
Im Bereich Barrierefreiheitsstärkungsgesetz und bestimmte Produkte und Dienstleistungen
haben wir einen Mechanismus der Marktüberwachung drin.
Da muss ich dann ab nächstem Jahr zeigen, wie gut der funktioniert,
um dann tatsächlich die Barrierefreiheit durchzusetzen.
Woran scheitert es noch?
Oder eine Forderung, die wir immer wieder stellen, ist, dass das Thema Barrierefreiheit
stärker auch in den Ausbildungen berücksichtigt werden muss,
weil unsere Erfahrung zurzeit ist,
dass es schon ein größeres Bewusstsein für das Thema digitale Barrierefreiheit gibt.
Also als ich angefangen habe, 2008 mich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen,
da hatte ich immer das Gefühl, wenn ich digitale Barrierefreiheit sage,
entsteht so ein Vakuum über den Köpfen.
Das ist nicht mehr der Fall. Mich erinnert total an die ganze Debatte um IT-Sicherheit
und auch an der Ausbildung, wo wir auch schon seit zehn Jahren sagen,
man muss die IT-Sicherheit mit in die Ausbildung von Technikern bringen.
Mir erscheint, da sind viele Parallelen zur Barrierefreiheit.
Das glaube ich unbedingt auch.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du das für die IT-Sicherheit auch so sagen kannst,
dass es da zumindest eine Entwicklung gibt, dass nicht mehr die Frage gestellt wird,
was ist das, sondern es halt eher momentan daran scheitert, wie machen wir es
und wie machen wir es richtig.
Und da muss man auch sagen, dass wir haben das nicht in den Ausbildungen drin
und es gibt einfach zu wenig Kompetenz,
die in den Stellen drin sind, die das tatsächlich umsetzen können.
Und da muss einfach ein viel, viel stärkerer Kompetenzaufbau im Thema stattfinden.
Ich glaube, es gibt noch eine Parallele zwischen der IT-Sicherheit und der Barrierefreiheit.
Nämlich, dass man, wenn man die Digitalisierung plant, dann von Anfang an mitdenken
muss. Das ist noch eine Parallele.
Das wird wenig gemacht, sowohl bei der Barrierefreiheit wie bei der IT-Sicherheit.
Und da würde ich den Bogen zu Jürgen Läber schlagen. Das ist doch genauso beim Datenschutz.
Das müsste man doch eigentlich auch von Anfang an mitdenken.
Genauso wie die IT-Sicherheit und Barrierefreiheit und daran krankt es doch
auch. Oder siehst du das anders, Jürgen?
Ich sehe das vollkommen so. Das ist auch eigentlich eine Sache,
viele der Vorschriften lassen sich relativ leicht umsetzen, aber auch da,
also mittlerweile haben wir mehr Leute, die darauf achten und mehr Personen,
die daran geschult sind,
aber häufig sind es eben noch nicht die Personen, die da entscheiden,
sondern da wird eher gesagt, wir machen jetzt die wirtschaftliche Entscheidung und das reicht dann.
Leider führt das in der öffentlichen Diskussion, aber häufig das zu,
dass eben dann der Datenschutz auch verteufelt wird und gesagt wird,
wir würden ja super digitalisieren machen, wenn nicht der Datenschutz wäre.
Das haben wir natürlich in anderen Bereichen noch krasser.
Also jetzt sozusagen, wir hätten auch die beste KI, wenn nicht der Datenschutz wäre und sowas.
Aber das sehen wir halt auch beim Thema Digitalisierung allgemein.
Und das ist dann natürlich so ein bisschen das Dilemma, das wir haben.
Weil auf der einen Seite natürlich, Datenschutz kann man relativ gut und einfacher umsetzen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, hey, wir setzen das jetzt alles durch,
dann führt man natürlich zu Verlangsamungen.
Und dann wird plötzlich der Datenschutz irgendwie noch schlechter gesehen.
Und dann kommen, und da stimme ich dir zu, Konstanze, wir können noch viel mehr,
noch bessere Regelungen einführen.
Die werden dann aber so auch gar nicht mehr kommen. Und das ist ein bisschen
die Beduldigung, bei der wir da sind.
Deswegen, ich sehe auch auf beiden Ebenen, also ich sehe sowohl,
dass wir noch bessere Vorschriften teilweise haben können, wir haben aber auch
schon sehr gute Vorschriften, die leider nicht ausreichend umgesetzt werden
und wenn man mich so fragt, ja was kann man da eigentlich dran ändern,
ich glaube vieles ist wirklich ein Mindset-Ding, dass man einfach sagt,
Datenschutz ist was Gutes, das hilft uns allen, wir sollten den mal auch wirklich
ordentlich durchsetzen.
Und das andere ist, glaube ich, auch das, was passiert eigentlich,
wenn ich was mache, was jetzt gegen Datenschutzvorschriften verstößt oder eben
auch gegen Grundrechte verstößt oder so.
Häufig ist das Ergebnis irgendwie, dass dann habe ich ein Gerichtsurteil,
das halt sagt, durftest du so nicht machen oder es gibt einen sehr,
sehr geringen Schadensersatz und davor fürchtet man sich dann gar nicht so sehr,
sondern man fürchtet sich dann eher davor,
ach okay, wir verlieren jetzt irgendwie Marktanteil oder sonst was.
Deswegen bringt man lieber schnell was raus, was dann vielleicht zu einem kleinen
Bußgeld führt, als dass man irgendwie sagt, nee, wir denken das alles mit und
machen das jetzt ordentlich.
Also heißt Bußgelderhöhung und eine GFF klagt mehr in Zukunft?
Also natürlich, das ist ja unsere Landschaft.
Nein, ich glaube, man muss natürlich immer auch überlegen, woran es liegt.
Aber große Konzerne, um die es ja an dem Bereich auch häufig geht,
Es geht ja jetzt nicht irgendwie um einen Digitalzwang durch eine BackerInnen-App um die Ecke oder so.
Die haben jetzt immer wenig Angst davor, wenn, wie jetzt neulich,
ein Bußgeld oder Schadensersatz in Höhe von 100 Euro kommt für einen Datenleck.
Das schreckt wenig ab das heißt man muss da schon auch gucken und auch beim
Start muss man mal ein bisschen mehr gucken sozusagen,
dass da auch eine Abschreckungswirkung vorhanden ist deswegen will ich jetzt
auch nicht sagen sozusagen immer hohe Bußgelder sind immer das Richtige aber
wenn man mit Big Tech zu tun hat,
dann ist so ein Bußgeld von 1000 Euro halt nichts wert.
Was machen wir denn jetzt aber mit dem Thema? Also jetzt haben wir sozusagen
das Thema Digitalzwang und diese ganze Diskussion auch in ihrer Schwierigkeit irgendwie aufgerollt.
Und es ist für mich tatsächlich sozusagen so, ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
das wird hier noch, also es ähnelt für mich eher der Diskussion um Barrierefreiheit
als der Diskussion um Datenschutz.
Weil für Datenschutz gibt es doch so harte Argumente im Sinne von,
da gibt es halt Droh-Szenarien, auch die sind schwer vermittelbar.
Aber so, ne, also was mit kompletter Totalüberwachung passieren kann,
das geht dann doch irgendwie, aber so Themen wie Barrierefreiheit oder eben
sozusagen Digitalzwang haben wir aber das Problem, dass es den Einzelnen,
also dass es sehr viele Einzelne gibt, die das nicht betrifft und deswegen so,
ja, also das mit der Bahncard, das ist halt jetzt irgendwie so übel,
aber ich meine, bei mir ist das halt in der App so.
Wie, vielleicht können wir das sozusagen zur Abschlussrunde machen,
ne, also Also bei all dem, was ihr gesagt habt, wird ja klar,
dass auf verschiedenen Ebenen Arbeit,
Not, also eigentlich wäre es die Aufgabe des Staates, aber die Erfahrung zeigt,
gucken wir mal, wie durchdacht einerseits und durchsetzungsstark einerseits sein wird.
Also sozusagen, wie kann man, können wir als Zivilgesellschaft dafür sorgen,
dass dieses Digitalzwang-Thema halt ein Thema ist,
was zur Zufriedenheit von möglichst allen Menschen verläuft und eben nicht dieses Schicksal teilt.
Das so, ja, da sind die Nerds wieder, die nerven halt irgendwie mit ihrem Kram
und die Innovationsfeindlichkeit.
Und es wäre jetzt nicht schöner, wenn wir alle mehr wie Elon Musk wären.
Oh je, wo jetzt gehen wir jetzt hin? Oh je.
Ja, Jana. Vielleicht kann ich da nochmal einhaken an dem Punkt Barrierefreiheit.
Das ist halt ein schwieriges Thema, weil das so wenige betrifft.
Das würde ich so nicht unterschreiben. Wir werden alle älter und mit dem Älterwerden
ergeben sich auch bestimmte Einschränkungen, die durchaus auch relevant sind.
Da muss man einfach auch sehen, dass das Thema Barrierefreiheit eine große Schnittmenge
zum Thema Usability und zur Freundlichkeit hat.
Und wenn wir davon sprechen, dass wir für Menschen mit Sehbehinderung bestimmte
Kontrastanforderungen brauchen.
Dann heißt das gleichzeitig, dass von dieser Forderung ganz,
ganz viele andere Menschen auch profitieren, weil man einfach Texte,
die diese Anforderungen erfüllen, viel, viel besser lesen kann.
Und das heißt, die Umsetzung von Barrierefreiheitsanforderungen führt eigentlich
insgesamt zu einer Verbesserung, zu einer Qualitätsverbesserung von Angeboten.
Es gibt natürlich Erfolgskriterien, die beziehen sich sehr stark darauf,
dass die Nutzung mit assistiven Technologien gewährleistet werden muss,
aber es gibt halt auch einiges an Kriterien, auch gerade wenn ich so in dem
Bereich Verständlichkeit denke,
die den großen Bereich Nutzerfreundlichkeit betreffen und damit eine Verbesserung
für nicht nur eine kleine Gruppe darstellen.
Aber das Problem ist ja sozusagen das ist ja sozusagen ein bekanntes Argument.
Ja, schon klar. Es führt in der Praxis nicht dazu, dass es besser gemacht wird.
Das ist ja auch unsere Aufgabe. Wer ist jetzt unsere?
Als Leute, die über Technik reden und Technik bewerten, klar zu machen,
dass Barrierefreiheit für genau jeden Menschen sinnvoll ist. Genau jeden.
Dass Barrieren nur unterschiedlich hoch sind für Menschen. Und genau so ist es mit dem Datenschutz.
Datenschutz-kompatible App, die diese Grundrechte von informationeller Selbstbestimmung
wahrt, die ist für jeden von Vorteil.
Und genauso ist es aus meiner Sicht mit so Fragen der Ausfallsicherheit.
Wenn ich Systeme baue, die auch ausfallsicher sind und dann sind sie halt auch
oft mit einer analogen Komponente kombiniert, dann nutzen die erstmal allen.
Und ich glaube, das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt an dieser Digitalzwang-Debatte,
die die wir stark machen müssen, also die in ihrer Vielfältigkeit darzustellen,
nicht platt werden zu lassen und an diejenigen, die Digitalisierungsprojekte
umsetzen und die sinnvolle Kritik abkriegen, also das auch weiterzuführen.
Ich finde es schön, dass wir diese Bahn-App-Debatte hatten, weil meine Hoffnung
immer ist, dass es ein bisschen...
Spezifizierter dann über die Probleme gesprochen werden kann und eben nicht
beerdigt wird, indem ein Konzern zwei Pressemitteilungen macht.
Und dann hat auch die Gruppen, die man nicht so sichtbar hat,
also Leute, die zum Beispiel einkommensschwächer sind oder die ein bisschen
Angst vor Geräten haben und sind ja meistens auch ältere Leute,
also eine gewisse Ohnmacht gegenüber den Geräten mitzudenken.
Tja, da hätten wir schon eine Menge gewonnen. Wir müssen das glaube ich einfach
am Leben behalten, ansonsten wird es wird überrollen. Das scheint mir eine große Welle zu sein.
Also, guter Vorsatz fürs nächste Jahr, mehr über Digitalzwang reden.
Vielleicht müssen wir den Begriff loswerden. Wir haben vor der Sendung auch
mal kurz überlegt, ob man das nicht anders framen könnte, einen anderen Begriff
dafür finden kann, weil mich der Begriff ein bisschen abstößt.
Ich kann Digitalisierung eben auch in vielen Bereichen möchte,
auf eine bestimmte Weise möchte und diese Zwang klingt für mich immer so negativ,
aber wir haben keinen gefunden.
Ich glaube, da kommt man auch nicht zusammen, weil ich finde es tatsächlich was Negatives.
Es hat oft was Negatives, aber ich sehe halt auch die Bereiche,
wo es unglaublich nützlich ist und wo ich sozusagen nicht mit so einer merkwürdigen
Debatte Leute verschrecken möchte.
Ich möchte ja, dass Leute offen sind für die Argumente, weißt du?
Die wir ja hier heute, also die sind ja nun mal komplex. Ich weiß nicht,
wenn jemand einen anderen schönen Begriff dafür hätte, wäre sehr happy.
Also ich habe keinen, aber ich kann dem vollumfänglich zustimmen.
Also ich wäre da auch sehr dankbar für, wenn wir da einen besseren Begriff für finden würden.
Also nun haben sich manchmal Begriffe etabliert. Wir fragen mal Jürgen,
Juristen sind doch immer super mit Definitionen und Begriffen.
Also Juristen sind super mit Begriffen.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob das der Verständlichkeit zuträglich ist. Durchaus nicht.
Oder Oder magst du den Begriff?
Also ich habe damit auch tatsächlich kein Problem, weil ich das auch eher als
was Negatives sehe, aber ich glaube sozusagen, es hängt ja auch davon ab,
also für mich ist der Digitalzwang nicht gleich Digitalisierung.
Das ist korrekt. Und ich glaube, genau, sobald man das aber stark miteinander
verbindet, dann hat man plötzlich auch einen negativen Anstrich gegenüber der Digitalisierung.
Ich hätte sonst tatsächlich auch einfach an Dinge gedacht, aber das ist dann
auch wieder zu kurz gegriffen, weil ich fand eigentlich sehr schön,
wie wir viel heute auch geframed haben im Sinne von Barrierefreiheit.
Und wie sozusagen Barrierefreiheit uns allen nützt.
Also sozusagen dann eher noch an das anknüpft, sozusagen, also Jana,
digitale Barrierefreiheit und das also einen Unteraspekt einfach davon zu sehen.
Und ich glaube, das ist halt was sehr, sehr Positives wiederum.
Oder würde ich zumindest so verstehen. Aber da bist du eher die Expertin als
ich, ob man das so sehen kann oder ob das dann vielleicht auch negative Assoziationen
für andere Teile deiner Arbeit irgendwie dann herbeiführen könnte.
Muss man sagen, Jana, würde das irgendwie auch negative Auswirkungen haben?
Ich glaube, ich habe den Zusammenhang nicht richtig nicht verstanden.
Vielleicht kannst du es nochmal wiederholen.
Genau, also für mich ist das dieses so, also die Begriffe, die wir jetzt haben,
ist einmal Digitalzwang und dann gibt es ja so ein bisschen,
ist nicht deckungsgleich, aber dieses Recht auf Analoges ist ja so ein bisschen.
Auch die Überlegung, wie man das positiver frame kann, wo wir aber auf alle
Füge gesagt haben, nee, das wollen wir nicht. Oder sozusagen,
oder da sehen wir auch Kritik dran.
Als wollen wir nicht so platt, haben wir gesagt. Mit den Füßen wurde abgestürmt sozusagen.
Und naja, also deswegen ist halt über meine Überlegung, also wir hatten ja schon
gesprochen, also das ist halt ein sehr, sehr relevanter Aspekt davon,
warum wir eigentlich ein Problem damit haben, ist die Barrierefreiheit.
Und dass man dann eben sozusagen sagt, wir framen das nicht als sozusagen,
also die Arbeit, die man da tut, wo man sagt, wir wollen dafür sorgen,
dass es eine analoge Alternative gibt,
dass wir das einfach als Teil der Barrierefreiheit oder dann noch spezifischer
der digitalen Barrierefreiheit irgendwie so tituliert eher.
Ich würde da glaube ich nicht den Begriff der Barrierefreiheit,
sondern eher den Begriff der Teilhabe verwenden, weil es glaube ich eher darum geht.
Es geht darum Teilhabe zu ermöglichen und da Menschen nicht auszuschließen.
Und wenn du es unter diesem Begriff der Teilhabe fasst, dann kannst du darunter
sowohl fassen, dass es halt mehrere Zugänge haben sollte,
als auch, dass es barrierefrei und inklusiv gestaltet werden sollte.
Da fehlt mir jetzt aber ein Aspekt.
Ich will ja trotzdem, wenn es noch so toll barrierefrei gestaltet ist und nur
super gui hat und flutscht, ich will ja trotzdem nicht irgendwie 37.000 Tracker
mit einer App reingedrückt bekommen.
Aber das ist doch, ich glaube sozusagen, du unterstellst jetzt eine Simplizität,
die in dem Lösungsvorschlag, also Jana, korrigier mich, wenn ich das jetzt überinterpretiere,
enthalten ist, weil Teilhabe bedeutet ja Teilhabe für alle Menschen,
das bedeutet auch Teilhabe für die Menschen, die nicht überwacht werden wollen,
das heißt, es ist schon da auch mit drin.
Ach, meinst du? Na dann würde ich mich da wohlfühlen, das Digitalisierungsopfer.
Ich habe Jana so verstanden, Jana kann jetzt korrigieren, wenn ich es falsch verstanden habe.
Ja, doch. Also ich finde, das kann man schon so verstehen und sagen,
man möchte Leute halt nicht, man möchte keine Exklusion von Gruppen vorantreiben.
Und da geht es dann halt sowohl um diejenigen, die halt digitale Angebote oder
Apps nicht nutzen können, als auch diejenigen, die sie nicht nutzen wollen aus bestimmten Gründen.
Oh Mann, ein versöhnliches Ende. Man kann tatsächlich sagen,
wir reden ja im Prinzip um Digitalisierung im Sinne von digitaler Lösung.
Und da kann man das digital eigentlich weglassen. Man kann sagen,
gesellschaftliche Lösungen oder Lösungen für die Gesellschaft sind nur dann
Lösungen, wenn sie alle mit einschließen.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber Meter, oder? Ich dachte, zum Ende gönne ich uns noch
einen kleinen Kalenderspruch.
Wo sich wirklich jeder hinter versammeln kann. Und jetzt gehen wir wieder in
den Alltag und werden wieder gezwungen, blöde Apps runterzuladen,
die uns tracken und die keine Gui haben und die man nicht benutzen kann und
wo die Schrift immer dieselbe Größe hat.
Darf ich vorstellen, Konstanze Kurz, Digitalisierungsopfer und bis zum Schluss
gewillt, alle Dinge anzuzünden, vielen lieben Dank, dass du heute dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Jürgen Bering von der GFF, vielen Dank, dass du heute dabei warst.
Danke für die Einladung. Und Jana Mattert vom Deutschen Blinden- und Sehbehindertenverband,
vielen Dank, dass du heute dabei warst.
Ja, vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Und vielen Dank, lieber Markus,
dass du wieder unser Moderator warst. Das war eine einzige Freude.
Das freut mich wiederum sehr. Ich verabschiede mich von euch,
liebe HörerInnen, für dieses Jahr.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Vielleicht sogar auf dem KS Communication Kongress,
der wieder zwischen den Jahren ist.
Berichtet, wie es dort war. Ich werde dieses Jahr nicht da sein.
Aber das Thema Barrierefreiheit, das Thema Tracking wird vorhanden sein.
Alles klar. lest den Fahrplan oder hört den Fahrplan, je nachdem, wie es euch möglich ist.
Mir bleibt jetzt am Ende dieser Sendung und am Ende dieses Jahres wie immer
nur noch eine Sache zu sagen.
Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.
Tschüss. Tschüss. Ciao, ciao.
Music.